you mentioned re and Lauren's wedding
you've officiated bachelor weddings
before will we see you there at you will
definitely oh I say we need to see me at
the wedding
hi you will see me at the wedding and
you know what I can announce to you
breaking news lauren zima that i will be
officiating re and Lauren's wedding oh
that is very exciting and it's something
they called me what a couple months ago
when they announced and I was actually
driving down to my son's lacrosse
tournament and they called and they were
both on the phone and they said you know
we would really love it if you would fly
out and officiate the wedding for so we
can't think of anyone better and I am I
really I was touched I'm honored and
again it goes to show just how much we
do care and love about these people and
and how tight we all are off-camera and
so there's a few of us from producers
and from the bachelor family that are
going to fly out and be in Hawaii and I
will be there to do officiate the
wedding I'm glad to hear that actually
because there were a lot there was a lot
of talk like how is Ari with the whole
crew because of the way things ended so
it sounds like you guys are all still
close we are still close today a lot is
made you know and some stuff some stuff
I think is get overblown because of how
traumatic it is on TV and I think
sometimes you think what happens on TV
spills over into our relationships and
and most the time it does not and we are
still close with most the majority of
the people on the show and so anything
again it says a lot when people come
back to be the bachelor Bachelorette and
it says a lot when they call you and say
hey will you stand before us and before
God and officiate our wedding and so it
really is I don't take it lightly it's
an honor to stand before all the couples
and do that and it's something that's
very sacred to me and I'm a faith driven
man and so it's a powerful thing to be
able to do that for people well there be
a bachelor joke in the statements that
you make you know I'm not the most
serious person all the time so there
will be some anecdotal jokes there and
you know and we have a baby on the way
yeah so maybe there's a okay
yeah about maybe the fact that we jumped
the gun on on the honeymoon suite it's
an unconventional yeah
[Music]